[Musique]
la durée de notre réunion et de l'ordre
d'une heure une heure 10 le ministre
devant se rendre à une réunion pour 18h
se faire de ma part c'est le ministre
vous avez accepté de venir cet
après-midi de vendre notre commission
pour évoquer la situation que le pays
vient de vivre il y a maintenant
plusieurs jours pour ne pas dire
plusieurs nuits
bien sûr que l'origine de l'événement
est un événement dramatique
mais en aucun cas cet événement
dramatique ne peut justifier les émeutes
qui ont eu lieu ensuite et la violence
j'allais dire la déferlante de violence
qui s'est
envahit le pays en tous les cas un grand
nombre de villes de villages vous l'avez
rappelé aux questions d'actualité
de toute nature y compris sur des
critères que nous n'avons pas l'habitude
d'avoir c'est-à-dire des villages
paisibles voire des communes paisibles
j'en connais quelques-unes qui ont été
la cible d'incendie d'automobile ou de
bâtiments ou de tirs de mortier
les images de télévision
ont montré la violence avec laquelle
cette situation a été a eu lieu vous
avez mobilisé beaucoup de personnels de
police bien sûr
les pompiers ont été mobilisés les
magistrats vous l'avez cela a été
rappelé ont été aussi mobilisés pour
apporter une réponse pénale rapide
mais il n'empêche que sur le fond les
questions demeure aujourd'hui si la
situation est apaisée nous devons sans
doute vous en féliciter il n'en demeure
pas moins que on s'interroge tous de
savoir pour combien de temps
et on s'interroge tous pour savoir quel
remède demain
ce que nous partageons comme constat et
c'est là-dessus que nous souhaiterions
vous entendre c'est qu'en réalité
mérit bibliothèque espace public
lieu communal au lieu d’état voire
tribunaux ont été attaqués incendiés y
compris la maison d'arrêt de Fresnes
en réalité on se rend compte aujourd'hui
que c'est la République
c'est l'autorité qui est attaquée d'une
façon générale
les événements d'hier au tribunal
judiciaire de Lyon l'occasion de
l'audience qui devait juger les
personnes qui ont été arrêtées et
renvoyés devant le tribunal le fait que
cette audience ait été suspendue parce
que des militants
du dragon était présent on perturbait
l'audience en insultant d'ailleurs la
police dans un lieu de justice
sont autant d'éléments qui nous
interrogent sur la suite des événements
sur les motivations réelles des voyous
délinquants ou criminels
je ne parle même pas des agressions
portées à l'égard des élus bien sûr
les événements récents concernant le
maire de la commune de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses mais je rappelle quand
même de Lyon pas trop vite le maire de
Saint-Brévin je rappelle madame le Maire
de Plougrescant je rappelle beaucoup
d'autres qui depuis ce système manifesté
pour dire qu'ils étaient les victimes de
violence
dans mon département amer à lui-même
était aussi
attaqué à son domicile
bref tout est dit la situation est
dramatique la réponse
policière et la remise en ordre est en
cours et vous l'avez menée et ne vous
soutenons la question de fond et de
savoir comment demain les choses
évolueront et comment nous réagirons aux
attaques contre la République mais non
cette situation nous voulons nous
explications monsieur le ministre sur
qui a fait quoi comment comprendre les
choses et essayer de déterminer la
réalité des choses car nous sommes tous
bien convaincus ici que l'ensemble des
populations des quartiers appelés de
banlieue des quartiers difficiles sont
des gens qui ont envie de vivre
tranquille
qui ont envie d'éduquer leurs enfants
qui se sont inscrits évidemment dans la
République quelle autre réplique
exactement et qui avec leurs moyens
essayent de évidemment vivre normalement
donc il est bien question de faire une
réflexion de fonds de ne pas faire masse
de tout de s'interroger précisément sur
les causes mais de bien c'est vous qui
pouvez nous donner cette analyse voilà
Monsieur Miss je suis déjà beaucoup trop
long il y aura sans doute des questions
de la part des collègues mais nous avons
donc je vous le rappelle mes chers
collègues une heure de temps
merci monsieur le Président comme à
chaque fois que bien sûr une commission
des lois m'invite à expliquer l'élection
du gouvernement j'y réponds
favorablement je m'en excuse si vers 18h
comme je vous l'ai dit je vous demande
de quitter votre commission car je
préside d'autres réunions de sécurité
puisque si la situation est calme elle
est à surveillée comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même monsieur le Président après
ces moments extrêmement difficiles
le mardi 27 juin
2023 à 8h16 avenue Frédéric et Irène
Joliot-Curie à Nanterre des effectifs de
la DOPC c'est-à-dire le service de
l'ordre public et de la circulation la
préfecture de police ont voulu procéder
au contrôle d'un véhicule avec trois
individus à son bord qui circulaient
manifestement sur une voie de bus le
conducteur de la voiture voiture
immatriculée en Pologne mais non
signalés à refusé d'obtempérer d'après
le rapport de la police nationale aux
injonctions des policiers puis est finie
par couper le contact passage François
Arago à Nanterre le conducteur a alors
manifestement subitement redémarré
le fonctionnaire de police comme tout le
monde l'a vu sur cette vidéo a fait
usage à une reprise de son arme
administrative il s'agissait d'un
policier expérimenté de 38 ans qui ne
connaissait aucune difficulté dans son
casier et qu'elle avait été décorée à
plusieurs reprises il était accompagné
par un autre policier expérimenté de 40
ans qui lui aussi ne connaissait pas de
difficultés particulière avec son
administration les véhicules a fini sa
course encastron dans une barrière et un
poteau le conducteur qui manifestement a
été blessé au thorax était en arrêt
cardio-respiratoire les effectifs de
police qui sont arrivés en prodigués un
premier massage cardiaque avant
l'arrivée des sapeurs-pompiers du Samu
qui ont pris de relais mais le
conducteur blessé a été déclaré des CD à
9h15 le premier passager arrière
toujours dans le véhicule a été
immédiatement interpellé le deuxième
passager non identifiant des faits a
pris la fuite il a depuis chacun la vue
était identifié c'est-à-dire exprimé
dans les médias il a été contrôlé dans
la nuit du samedi 1er juillet en
violation d'un contrôle judiciaire sur
ses horaires de sortie est placé en
rétention judiciaire il a été remis à
l'issue de la mesure à ses civils
responsable puisque il était comme le
conducteur non majeur au moment des
faits le procureur de la République a
saisi l'inspection générale de la police
nationale et nous avons fait pareil en
administratif au même moment
et cela en mené l'enquête vous avez vu
qu'ils ont mis en garde à vue les
policiers le policier qui a utilisé son
tir administratif au bout de 48 heures
le policier était présenté devant des
magistrats instructeurs une information
judiciaire a été ouverte il a été mis en
examen et placé en détention provisoire
et m'appartient pas plus en amont de
discuter évidemment de l'enquête
judiciaire ni des suites judiciaires ce
sera évidemment
au parquet ou à la chancellerie de
communiquer à la suite évidemment de cet
événement absolument dramatique pour
lequel je crois très rapidement le
gouvernement a fait transparence et à
utiliser me semble-t-il les mots qu'il
convenait tout en rappelant que ce
policier a le droit comme toute personne
à la présomption d'innocence qui n'est
pas condamné définitivement il y a eu
une nuit celle qui a suivi immédiatement
qui aurait pu être une nuit de désordre
public et je voudrais ici dire que le
ministère de l'Intérieur s'est préparé
immédiatement au fait qu'il pouvait
avoir des manifestations et donc il a
mis en place un dispositif d'ordre
public et cette manifestation ces
manifestations n'ont pas eu lieu puisque
ce que nous avons constaté de la
première nuit ce sont des violences
urbaines à Nanterre c'est tout à fait
vrai mais dans d'autres villes de France
par effet de mimétisme très certainement
on y reviendra et donc la posture du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui est
évidemment d'éviter un autre drame
passer à ma demande d'une position
d'ordre public à une position de lutte
contre les violences urbaines ce qui
explique à la fois la mobilisation de
moyens extrêmement différents mais aussi
la stratégie a mis en place par les
préfets sous mon autorité et
singulièrement par le préfet de police
même s'il n'a pas été le seul au
rendez-vous bien sûr de cette action je
voudrais en remercier ici les préfets
les équipes de direction générale de la
police nationale la gendarmerie
nationale de la Préfecture de Police de
la DGSI qui a été également mobilisé
l'ensemble bien sûr des forces de
l'ordre y compris des sapeurs et des
polices municipales qui ont contribué à
ce travail nous avons connu pendant ces
moments très difficiles donc je peux
compter ce moment difficile entre le 27
juin et aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président même si les deux dernières
nuits ont été extrêmement calmes
23878 feux de voie publique et
saguillèrement des poubelles
12031 véhicules incendiés
2508 bâtiments incendiés ou dégradés
dont 273 bâtiments qui appartiennent aux
forces de l'ordre police nationale
gendarmerie ou police municipale
derrière les pays municipales ont payé
un autre tribu à ces attaques
inacceptables 105 mairies incendie ou
dégradées 168 écoles on fait l'objet
d'attaque qu'elle soit et sur la même
période 17 atteintes aux élus ont été
recentrés recensés par le mystère de
l'Intérieur donc bien sûr le cas de
Monsieur le Maire de l'Aïd les roses
évidemment devant une violence
extrêmement forte et devant une posture
d'interpellation sont exigées par mes
soins
les services de la police nationale
gendarmerie ont procédé à 35005
interpellations dont 1373 dans la seule
zone de la préfecture de police
c'est-à-dire Paris et sa petite couronne
du notamment au fait que nous avons
demandé comme chacun a vu dès le
deuxième jour que les brigades
d'intervention qui d'habitude sont
utilisés en judiciaire je parle du raid
du GIGN de la BRI ou des pelons de la
gare de républicaine ont été mobilisés
dans toutes les villes de France et ont
procédé à ces très nombreux
interpellations je crois dans des
conditions conformes à la loi et à la
déontologie et aux principes de
proportionnalité que je leur ai demandé
même s'il peut y avoir des moments
dramatiques et évidemment on entend ici
ou là le fait que cela puisse exister il
n'y a à ma connaissance que 10 saisit de
l'IGPN ou de l'iggn dans des cas
particuliers pour l'instant pour lequel
je n'ai que très peu d'informations et
pour le quai d'ailleurs des enquêtes
judiciaires te sont ouvertes je vais
donc remercier les policiers des
gendarmes puisqu'ils ont agi dans des
conditions difficiles on les a rappelé
de leurs congés on a annulé des
formations on a rappelé des missions
comme les CRS des plages pour que bien
évidemment puissent répondre à cette
problématique on a organisé des
continuités de service qui était au-delà
des horaires je saurai monsieur le
Président en tant que chef
d'administration mission intérieur les
remercier symboliquement et plus que
cela évidemment pour cette mobilisation
parce que c'est leur mobilisation et
leur professionnalisme qui a permis de
rassurer les élus limiter les attaques
même s'ils ont été extrêmement
nombreuses et je veux le dire ici
augmenter un nombre d'interpellations
jamais retenues qui a permis une réponse
pénale que je crois est forte même si je
n'ai pas tous les chiffres et que on
sait tous que la réponse pénale met du
temps après les interpellations et les
garde à vue continuez à travailler de
police judiciaire je reviendrai monsieur
le garde monsieur le Président la
Commission des lois parce que nous avons
évidemment à travailler en judiciaire
pour pouvoir interpeller dans la journée
tous ceux qui commettaient des méfaits
la nuit et ça contribuer très largement
me semble-t-il au calme juré quelques
exemples à vous donner et en confiant la
police judiciaire je voudrais dire à
Monsieur Durin peut-être avec facétie
similaire en préfigurant la réforme de
la police nationale nous avons su je
crois retrouver énormément de monde et
notamment énormément interpellé de
personnes dans la journée qu'elles m'ont
insigne partie des ardeurs des émeutiers
et des délinquants et nous avons su me
semble-t-il protéger quelques symboles
extrêmement forts et nous avons vu
transformer finalement ce mouvement qui
était des mouvements d'attaque
évidemment c'est un peu caricatural
parce qu'il faut regarder territoire par
territoire des attaques symboles de la
République école commissariat mairie
brigade de gendarmerie poste de police
municipale centre socio en pillage de
commerçants qui étaient la deuxième
phase si j'ose dire de cette de cette
série de nuit extrêmement extrêmement
difficile
vous aurez donc compris que les mineurs
que nous avons interpellés sont
extrêmement jeunes pour la plupart pour
la plupart d'entre eux comme j'ai dit
aux questions gouvernement monsieur le
Président nous pouvons constater par
ailleurs que à notre connaissance seul
10% des personnes que nous avons
interpellées sur de nationalités non
françaises et d'ailleurs il y a eu 40
placements en centre de rétention
administratif ce qui est peu à vous le
sur 3500 personnes interpellées je
voudrais aussi souligner que comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure à ma connaissance 60%
des personnes que nous avons interpellé
n'ont pas de casier judiciaire et ne
sont pas connus des services de police
cette évidemment difficile d'aller plus
au delà de la sociologie de ces
personnes puisque après les
interpellations
ces personnes sont rentrées dans un
fichier qui s'appelle Casio p qui a
affiché judiciaire et la partie sans
doute à monsieur le garde des sceaux
donnaient des informations dans quelques
jours je vois que c'est un peu trop tôt
pour qu'il puisse le faire sur la
composition exacte des personnes pour
que nous comprenions leur origine
géographique et des motivations
éventuelles qui les ont amenées à
commettre ces méfaits aujourd'hui
monsieur le Président la posture du
ministère de l'intérieur c'est
évidemment d'être extrêmement attentif
ça repose sur trois grands piliers le
premier c'est une présence des forces de
l'ordre extrêmement forte sur le
territoire national je constate avec
vous que ni d'accords ni les outre-mer à
quelques exceptions près un peu la
Guyane un peu la Réunion mais très en
deçà de ce qu'a fait la métropole donc
il s'agit d'un sujet exclusivement
métropolitain ou quasi exclusivement
métropolitain rester très éveillés donc
pour la présence de voies publiques et
notamment la nuit
je constate également au deuxième point
que le travail que nous devons mener
aujourd'hui c'est un travail de police
judiciaire il y a énormément
d'interpellations au moment où je vous
parle de personnes qui sont confondues
par la police technique et scientifique
nous avons particulièrement mobilisé par
les services bien sûr la préjudiciaire
qui permet de ces interpellations c'est
pour ça que les chiffres
d'interpellation augmentent les
correspondent pas à des nuits d'émeutes
supplémentaires il correspondent au
travail de la PJ qui permet après coup
d'interpeller les personnes je pense pas
à la mairie de mons-en-barœul où je me
suis rendu 9 personnes étaient arrêtées
et vous aurez constaté qu'il s'agit de
manière extrêmement majoritaire de
mineur et évidemment ça pose un certain
nombre de problèmes qu'on se posera
sociologiquement et politiquement plus
tard mais on a vu qu'en 48 heures les
services de la police étaient capables
lorsqu'un feu avait ravagé le mairie
d'interpeller les personnes donc je le
remercier vraiment la grande
mobilisation des policiers qui font de
la police judiciaire et puis
troisièmement il s'agit maintenant de
lutter contre tout ce qui contribue
alors c'est pas une réponse structurelle
monsieur le Président conjoncturelle
armé les émeutiers on a eu peu de tirs
contre les policiers légendes je veux
cependant constater qu'à Nîmes un
policier a vu une balle de 9 mm dans son
gilet barbal qui aurait pu lui coûter sa
vie ce n'avait pas été bien équipé à
Lyon en tout cas dans les alentours de
Lyon il y a des tirs à la chevrotine
contre des policiers qui ont blessé
plusieurs policiers on a vu ici où là
des alertes de personnes qui auraient eu
des armes longues et sur son service
souvent pour détruire des bâtiments
publics ou des caméras de
vidéosurveillance parce que le travail
des émeutiers était assez organisé une
fois qu'on s'attarde sur ce point aussi
sur le fait que il détruisait d'abord
des caméras de vidéos surveillance par
exemple avant d'intervenir et donc nous
n'avons pas vu à ma connaissance de tir
d'armes dit type kalachnikov sur les
forces de l'ordre mais il était
maintenant c'est un risque très
important mais en revanche les mortiers
ont été particulièrement utilisés chacun
peut le constater j'ai donc non
seulement demandé le lendemain de ces
émeutes de pouvoir faire que les préfets
sur tout le territoire national
la construction qu'on a constitution de
cocktail Molotov et donc ne vendent plus
de l'essence en bidon dans les stations
essence la difficulté évidemment c'est
que l'essence est parfois récupéré
directement des voitures et donc ça
limite la portée mais enfin c'était
quand même déjà assez et c'est efficace
et interdisent la vente c'est pour ça
que des fermetures administratives de
magasin dans vos territoires le contrôle
aux douanes et j'en remercie mystère des
grands publics pour les venus à
l'étranger je pense notamment vers
l'Allemagne la Belgique qui permet
d'acheter plus facilement des mortiers
mais également dans les tirs dans les
contrôles de pardon de relais postaux et
de colis puisque des commandes sont
faites illégalement sur Internet ou de
transport de mortier vous avez vu par
exemple une affaire puisque la
préjudiciaire suit désormais
particulièrement c'est filières il n'y a
pas d'autres mots nous avons fait par
exemple 300 kg à Porte de Clignancourt
ce matin ou hier soir je ne sais plus
qui montre l'efficacité des services de
préjudiciaires il est évident qu'une
partie des mortiers était stockée pour
la nuit du 13 au 14 juillet et peut-être
a été anticipé comme marbre par
destination je pense d'ailleurs à des
élus qui ont été le fait de s'étire dans
la maire de Pontoise qui était brûlée du
fait de notre sœur de mortier par
exemple chacun a pu le constater voilà
Monsieur monsieur le Président quelques
mots le fait déclenchant la façon de
gérer les choses et la façon dont il
compte les gérer demain ou après-demain
il est bien difficile de savoir ce qui
va se passer dans les jours qui viennent
nous constatons cependant un calme
revenu partout sur le territoire
national et nous sommes toujours
évidemment extrêmement attentif aux
heures et aux jours qui merci Monsieur
le Ministre plusieurs collègues ont
demandé la parole d'abord Madame
Jacqueline stage brignot Monsieur Jérôme
Durin Madame Brigitte l'herbier Monsieur
François bonhomme madame Marie-Pierre de
la Gontrie madame difolco monsieur
alamarque monsieur le Président de
canner et
la massassy et Madame Gatel
merci d'être venu dans nous aujourd'hui
je sais que votre tâche n'est pas facile
les tâches des élus dont je fais partie
n'est pas facile non plus moi tout
d'abord je voulais rendre hommage à la
police au gendarmes aux papiers du
Val-d'Oise qui depuis des nuits ne
dorment pas et font face à comme vous
l'avez dit des émeutiers et je pense que
chacun d'entre nous doit comprendre que
la plupart des Français soutiennent tous
ces effectifs de police de gendarmerie
et de pompiers parce que ce qu'il
constate aujourd'hui je peux vous dire
qu'il y a aujourd'hui des habitants qui
s'expriment de manière assez effrayante
parfois et parce qu'ils sont exaspérés
les Français aujourd'hui c'est la
réalité donc on a beaucoup parlé depuis
quelques jours bon je remercie vous nous
avez donné des informations certaines on
les avait mais je vous remercie de les
avoir expliqué je reviendrai pas sur le
drame parce que tout le monde constate
que ce qui s'est passé tiendra mais
est-ce que ça justifiait ce que nous
avons vécu moi je crois pas moi je le
dis clairement ça ne justifie pas ce que
la France a connu ce drame ne le
justifie à aucun moment voilà ça c'est
clair alors on s'est beaucoup posé de
questions effectivement à juste titre
sur l'argent qu'on a dépensé depuis des
années pour certains quartiers et je
fais partie de ces élus qui s'est
beaucoup battu pour la politique de la
ville et je fais partie de ces élus
aujourd'hui qui se questionne beaucoup
pour du ticket de cet argent public
qu'on a beaucoup dépensé donc
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous poser des
questions parce que il y a des sujets
dont on ne veut pas parler monsieur le
ministre mais je souhaite qu'on en parle
moi je vis pas dans le sixième dans le
septième ou dans le 8e je vais dans le
95 donc voilà je voulais juste le
préciser et moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé
pour faire en sorte que tous les avants
quelle que soit leur origine et leur
couleur de peau vivent sur le code de la
République parce que je pense que c'est
une chance pour tous les enfants de ce
pays quel qu'il soit sauf qu'aujourd'hui
force est de constater que oui vous
allez me dire
la plupart des gens qui ont été arrêtés
sont français d'accord mais ça ne veut
plus rien dire aujourd'hui ils sont
comment en français et moi ça
m'interroge donc je voudrais savoir
quand même si un jour afin que nous
puissions y travailler nous allons
pouvoir connaître quels sont ces enfants
issus l'immigration ici l'immigration
pour lequel probablement des choses ont
été ratées puisqu'ils ne considère pas
comme français puisqu'ils ont une haine
de la France que moi élue
malheureusement depuis quelques années
je n'ai jamais ressenti comme je le
ressens aujourd'hui cette haine de la
France certains gamins dans les
banlieues sont capables de dire à des
gens d'origine africaine totalement
intégrées tu es noir dehors mais tu es
blanc dedans c'est pas neutre cette
phrase ce n'est pas ne cette phrase donc
si on ne pose pas ça si on ne dit pas ça
et si on essaye pas de comprendre qu'il
y a quelque chose que collectivement on
a raté je pense que nous n'y arriverons
pas donc pourquoi ne pas un jour avoir
l'honnêteté nous dit que la plupart des
jeunes qui ont commis des exactions
depuis qu'à 5 jours sont
issus l'immigration c'est une réalité
c'est factuels et être dans l'ennemi
dans le déni ne nous permet pas
d'avancer voilà et moi je me pose une
question qui est responsable de cette
haine de la France alors que ce pays a
accueilli sans réserve parce que c'est
normal parce que c'est la générosité de
la France leurs parents leurs
grands-parents ça n'a posé de problème à
personne et que deux ou trois
générations après nous en sommes là donc
ne pas vouloir nous donner les chiffres
de ces mots issus d'immigration qui ont
pillé qui ont cassé ne nous permettra
pas d'avancer pour deux raisons c'est
que 16 ans mais non je voudrais juste
finir je voudrais juste finir ses
enfants là n'ont pas eu aussi au sein de
leur famille une transmission de leur
propre histoire parce qu'ils ont une
histoire ces enfants là leurs parents
sont pas arrivés par hasard et c'est
aussi aux parents de transmettre
l'histoire familiale l'histoire
familiale elle se porte elle se et elle
se défend et si nous ne parlons pas de
cette réalité là Monsieur ministre nous
n'y arriverons pas merci madame monsieur
Durand oui pour être dans une réalité
qui n'est pas alternative parce que je
crois qu'il n'y a quand même qu'une
catégorie de Français les Français et
puis il y a ceux qui sont les 10% qui
ont été cités par le ministre qui ne
sont pas des Français mais on va pas
entrer quand même dans le détail
génétique des populations dont on parle
un peu choquant les propos de notre
collègue monsieur le ministre je vais
d'abord vous dire que nous sommes
satisfaits du dispositif de sécurité qui
a mis en oeuvre on sait que les
situations étaient difficiles pour les
forces de l'ordre et qu'il a fallu
beaucoup de
coordination d'efforts de leur part
toutes catégories confondues pour que la
situation qui était bien mal engagée ça
pèse et on espère que l'apaisement
durable vous dire que j'ai observé dans
mon propre département à Mâcon une
excellente coordination sous la houlette
du préfet entre différentes catégories
de force de l'ordre les gendarmes
mobiles le GIGN le commissariat local la
BAC il faut rendre hommage à tous ceux
qui ont contribué à au retour de
l'apaisement trois questions en rafale
la loop me et l'article
435-1 de du code de sécurité à
l'intérieur on a beaucoup débattu
pendant le refus d'obtempérer
on était revenu sur la loi de 2017 j'ai
entendu le garder ceux indiqué qu'il
était pas hostile à un vrai examen en la
matière et
notre proposition de
d'amendement et de modification du texte
et toujours sur la table je voulais
savoir si vous aviez des chiffres
comparés des refuses de tempérer pour ce
qui concerne d'un côté la police de
l'autre côté la gendarmerie qui pourrait
être nous éclairer sur la façon dont ça
se passe sur le territoire national en
la matière deuxième sujet c'est celui
des déclarations d'un bloc syndical
majoritaire dans la police qui nous ont
beaucoup choqué tout à l'heure on s'est
mis aux questions gouvernement du
syndicat de la magistration et de ses
propos j'aurais aimé aussi qu'on puisse
s'inquiéter de ce qui a été dit dans un
tract ou des syndicats policiers
voulaient s'en prendre aux nuisibles des
carrés en guerre voire en résistance
voilà je pense que c'est très inquiétant
et je voulais savoir quel est votre
réaction sur ce sujet et puis dans une
paysage politique où il n'est plus
d'extrême gauche je voulais savoir ce
que vous pensez des milices des
initiatives qui sont produites sur
l'ensemble du territoire ou des
citoyens on sait qu'il y a eu quelques
militaires à Lorient ce sont organisés
spontanément pour venir en ordre aux
forces de l'ordre là aussi une forme
d'inquiétude nous habite merci merci
monsieur Durand Madame Brigitte
l'herbier
oui monsieur le ministre vous savez
évoqué un nombre important de mineurs
interpellé lors des émeutes le président
Macron a insisté sur la reprise en main
nécessaire de l'autorité parentale par
les parents sur ses enfants délinquants
je suis absolument d'accord avec ce
besoin d'encadrement familial et où tout
au moins un encadrement éducatif chargé
d'autorité sur l'enfant j'aimerais
monsieur le ministre que vous soyez
quand même en messager auprès de
monsieur le Président de la République
pour évoquer le besoin d'entendre aussi
les enfants en bas âge en souffrance
dans leur foyer
270 enfants sont sous ordonnés
judiciaire de placement dans le Nord
depuis plusieurs mois
considérer en grand danger et
ses ordonnances ne sont pas suivies des
faits faute de place dans les foyers
largement occupé par les mineurs
étrangers isolés et par la difficulté à
recruter des nouvelles assistantes
familiales compétentes professionnelles
et moralement si l'enfant était éduqué
dans une violence dès son plus jeune âge
comment trouver un échappatoire rien
excuse les dégâts
occasionner ces derniers jours rien rien
ne justifierait de ne pas appliquer des
peines exemplaires tant aux mineurs
violents qu'à leur famille indifférente
à l'avenir de leur progéniture les
selles en bandeau rien car ces actes
sont inqualifiables impensables honteux
et nous remercions les forces de l'ordre
d'avoir été en première ligne merci
aussi aux pompiers aux élus symboles
visés par ces attaques mais on va devoir
travailler ensemble pour sauver notre
République
le président buffet et les membres de la
commission des lois sont prêts à
réfléchir sereinement pour éviter la
reprise de ce genre d'attaque
je pense qu'en amont un travail de
reprise en main de la situation de
l'enfance en danger est inévitable les
départements font de leur mieux mais
l'État doit les soutenir en priorité
dans leurs actions les enfants engagés
appellent depuis des mois voire des
années au secours le nombre de violences
familiales explosent les procureurs
généraux viennent d'ici régulièrement
l'évoquer au sein du Sénat
ne laissons pas les enfants évoluer dans
ces violences car il le reproduiront
peut-être si rien n'est fait monsieur le
ministre vous qui êtes proche des
concitoyens et je suis bien placé pour
le savoir à Tourcoing transmettez à
monsieur le Président qu'il est grand
temps de sauver les enfants en bas âge
ces situations que je viens d'évoquer
sont en parallèle de notre réflexion sur
la violence de ces derniers jours mais
tout est lié pour comprendre et
travailler sur l'avenir
il y a pas de question
je voudrais savoir ce que vous pouvez
très bien que penser de tous non non
c'était pas sûr que j'ai bien entendu
Monsieur Bonhomme
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre comme beaucoup en regardant les
images de ces derniers jours je me suis
posé la question suivante comment fait
divers tragique au demeurant a pu mettre
à feu et à s'entendre de vie dans notre
pays je crois que c'est la première fois
qu'on a vu un tel déferlement de
violence je suis comme la majorité des
Français a très grande majorité j'ai un
mélange de sidération de stupeur de
tristesse et de solidarité totale à
l'égard de nos forces de sécurité
policier gendarme et sapeurs-pompiers
les dégâts que nous avons que cela
occasionné sont considérables et il va
falloir payer et remettre un état tous
ces bâtiments publics tous ces incendies
tous ces véhicules brûlés
et indemniser tous les commerçants qui
ont été fortement impactés
naturellement cela débouche sur beaucoup
de questions et d'interrogations qu'il
ne s'agira pas ce soir avec une simple
audition d'essayer de traiter je pense
que les semaines et les mois qui vont
arriver vont être l'occasion vraiment
d'aller sur le fond des choses
naturellement aussi je voudrais ajouter
que la colère ne serait en aucun cas
constitué un passeport pour la violence
de même que rien absolument rien ne
serait justifié excusé son usage débridé
vous avez donc monsieur le ministre tout
notre soutien sans restriction face à la
façon dont l'ordre a été rétabli et si
cela doit passer dans les prochains mois
par une analyse de profonde et
nécessaire des causes on pourra
évidemment évoquer tout un tas
d'institutions ça n'est pas le ministère
de l'Intérieur qui est en cause c'est la
question évidemment de l'école de notre
rapport en France à l'autorité à tout ce
qui est verticale à la contestation
Toutes les figure de l'autorité qu'elles
soient juges qu'elle soit professeur
qu'elle soit mère ou qu'elle soit force
et qui a diffusé un sentiment de
déresponsabilité générale et sur fond
aussi quand même je voudrais le dire ici
d'un discours de complaisance ici et là
qui consiste à faire porter la
responsabilité sur d'autres causes qui
ne sont pas majeures en espèces je parle
la cause du racisme la cause de
l'insuffisance de la politique de la
ville le mépris social ou la
discrimination dont l'agent l'État
serait l'agent tout cela relève de la
simple dénégation du réel et nous mène
tout droit à une forme
d'irresponsabilité je rappelle que Ian
France qui tranquille et qui est
silencieuse qui elle a été également
sidérée par cette exposition de violence
et qu'elle attend d'abord un retour à la
paix à l'ordre et à la sécurité première
des libertés je voudrais maintenant vous
parler deux points et deux facteurs
particuliers qui me semblent avoir été
assez nouveau dans ces dans cette
explosion de violence d'abord le jeune
âge des yeux métiers vous l'avez dit un
grand nombre de personnes interpellées
au moins de 16 ans ou moins de 17 ans
c'est une jeunesse ça a été indiqué par
le monde qui est devenu hyper connecté
mais dans le même temps complètement des
culturé complètement déstructuré
socialement et dépourvu de toute retenue
et totalement désinhibée je crois que là
ça marque vraiment et ça donne la mesure
du renoncement dans cet homme de de nos
institutions qui ont été complètement
affaiblis et affaissés je pense
naturellement à l'école et puis deuxième
une question particulière sur l'usage
détourné qui a été fait par les mortiers
d'artifice nous avons vu des images tout
à fait spectaculaires ou les les
émeutiers sont procurés moult et force
mortier d'artifice par tout moyen
comment se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui on se
procure en France aussi facilement en
achète aussi facilement sur Internet
notamment des mortiers d'artifices qui
servent uniquement à cibler nos forces
de l'ordre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez depuis le début de
ces de ces difficultés et après la mort
du jeune à elle vous avez tenu des
propos que pour notre part nous avons
trouvé responsable
tentant évidemment au fil des événements
de faire en sorte que la paix civile
puisse revenir et on sait que dans ce
type de circonstances le pari n'est pas
gagné d'avance et nous l'avons vu vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure de manière
très responsable également
ce n'était pas exactement la formule
Mister pas loin bien malin celui qui
pense avoir la solution n'avait pas
utilisé exactement ces termes mais
c'était l'idée bienheureux voilà donc
effectivement gardons-nous de tout
Simplice mais de toute solution magique
il se pose cependant me semble-t-il
d'ores et déjà deux types de questions
auxquelles il nous faut répondre quand
je dis nous c'est parce que nous
considérons parlementaire que nous
sommes aussi acteurs de tout cela
la première c'est une question
d'ailleurs que mon collègue Jérôme
durain vous a posé sans doute en raison
du temps de réponse limité vous n'avez
pas pu y répondre complètement c'est
comment
réconcilier la police et la population
puisque sans être trop longue nous
voyons bien qu'il y a une difficulté de
ce point de vue là
et évidemment
comment faire face à ce qui peut être
perçu comme
une discrimination comme des pratiques
discriminatoires qui sont documentées et
comment faire face à ces situations sans
les nier sans les caricaturer nous les
caricaturons pas mais sans les nier et
je crains que certains ne les ne les ni
la deuxième chose c'est
les modalités de d'intervention des
forces de l'ordre est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas que il est nécessaire sans
doute de recadrer ou de préciser les
modalités d'usage des armes par les
forces de l'ordre sans doute que trois
séances de tir par an et largement
insuffisant pour que les personnels
soient en situation de réaction
suffisamment adaptée et donc au fond
toute la question de la formation des
policiers et sans doute en cause j'y
ajoute
sans doute la question de la
rémunération et au fond de la
considération que nous devons leur
apporter et on peut retrouver le serpent
de mer des millions d'heures
supplémentaires qui ne sont pas payées
et donc nous avons affaire évidemment
des forces de l'ordre exténuées et qui
ont évidemment beaucoup plus de
difficultés à accomplir leur mission
sereinement voilà les deux questions que
je souhaitais poser
Madame Catherine difolco
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre moi je suis inquiète parce
que j'ai entendu je crois que c'est
samedi soir un reportage radiophonique
c'est un journaliste qui était place
Bellecour à Lyon et qui interviewait des
jeunes voilà et qui est si jeune disais
on va pas y aller ce soir parce que ils
sont trop nombreux effectivement il y
avait beaucoup de force de police il y
avait le raid la Brice en doute je sais
plus exactement je ne dis on va rien
faire ce soir ils sont trop nombreux on
revient mais t'inquiète pas journaliste
ne t'inquiète pas on va revenir quand ce
sera le moment on reviendra donc moi
j'allais dire je suis inquiète parce que
vous n'avez pas pouvoir disposer des
dispositifs que vous avez mis en place
que la préfecture a mis en place à du
vitam eternam donc dès que les
dispositifs seront allégés ça risque de
reflammer de nouveau donc que
pensez-vous faire pour éviter merci
merci
[Musique]
merci Président je souhaite d'abord bien
évidemment comme d'autres collègues
rendre hommage ici aux forces de l'ordre
sapeurs-pompiers et dire à Monsieur le
Ministre que bien évidemment nous le
soutenons les uns et les autres ici
surtout ces bandes dans les actions
qu'il peut qu'il peut avoir pour
protéger les biens et les personnes sur
notre territoire nous sommes ici au
Sénat les représentants institutionnels
et constitutionnels des communes on sait
le rôle essentiel que représente les
mers au niveau certes des équipements
publics pour le mieux vivre de nos
populations mais aussi dans les nombreux
litiges qu'il parviennent à résoudre
faisant ainsi œuvre de justice de paix
c'est le qui a disparu dans les dans les
années 50 je crois savoir que vous avez
donné des consignes aux forces de
l'ordre afin que les élus soient
protégés eux qui sont aujourd'hui pris
pour cible par ceux qui ne supportent
pas notre démocratie
pouvez-vous nous dire quelle forme
prendra désormais cette coopération
d'autre part comptez-vous travailler
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale cela rejoint des questions qui
ont été préle préalablement posées afin
que nous institutions soit aussi à
nouveau apprise dans les programmes
scolaires et que leur portée symbolique
est nécessaire au fonctionnement de
notre société soit assimilée
merci Monsieur Marc président canner
merci Monsieur président monsieur le
ministre
premier mot pour n'ont pas répondre à
Madame stage Brignoud mais quand même
pour rappeler cette phrase qui dira
sûrement des choses à certaines
personnes je la cite nous pensons que
l'immigration fait partie de la France
et des Français depuis toujours
l'immigration est un fait qui fait aussi
la France qui a fait son passé qui fera
sans doute son avenir il ne sert à rien
d'être contre que veut dire être contre
le mouvement des hommes sur la Terre
Gérald Darmanin décembre 2022 Assemblée
nationale monsieur le ministre j'aurais
pu signer votre déclaration je le dis
très simplement et je pense que il ne
faut pas avoir notamment entre sénateur
madame ma chère collègue des propos
caricaturaux qui ne font que mettre de
l'huile sur le feu je le dis et je ferme
la parenthèse en la matière et je vous
invite à lire le l'excent ouvrage de
Monsieur héron François errant
professionnel
pandémie je reviens à notre sujet
initial monsieur le ministre
nous chercherons à comprendre les causes
et analyser et porter des propositions
d'ailleurs dans ce cadre au nom de mon
groupe j'ai demandé l'organisation d'un
débat parlementaire dans le cadre de
l'article 50-1 de la Constitution
j'espère que Madame borne pourra
répondre à cette sollicitation qui
relève de sa seule autorité
néanmoins nous avons une rencontre de
travail avec le Premier ministre il a 48
heures à Matignon avec l'ensemble des
prisons de groupe et j'ai pu rappeler au
nom de mon groupe ici représenté par
Madame de la ganterie et Monsieur du
Rhin
me retourne pour savoir non a priori
je j'ai interpellé combien de le faire
d'ailleurs notre collègue du Rhin sur la
formation des policiers sur
l'interprétation et l'évaluation de
l'article 435-1 du code de la sécurité
intérieure mais j'ai une question
complémentaire sur un sujet bien précis
mais qui prend toute sa place et son
importance dans le débat de ce jour à
savoir le développement et la
généralisation des caméras piétons
et
je ne vous cache pas ma surprise à la
réponse qui m'a été faite par la
première ministre me disant oui les
caméras piétons sont totalement
généralisées opérationnels moi j'y suis
très favorable depuis la loi égalité
citoyenneté de 2017 que nous avons porté
sur cette partie là avec Bernard
Cazeneuve et j'ai donc interrogé après
ministre sur le fait est-ce que les deux
motards incriminés à Nanterre portait
les caméras piéton il n'en portait pas
et par définition elles n'ont pas été
enclenchées puisque n'en partait pas je
considère nous considérons que les
caméras piétons ne sont pas l'alpha
Omega des solutions mais permettent de
sûrement d'apaiser une relation entre
incontrôlée et des personnes qui
apportent ce qui apportent ce contrôle
et la réponse d'après ministre m'a un
peu étonné mais je veux pas vous mettre
en difficulté monsieur le ministre mais
me disant mais quand on est motard on ne
porte pas de caméra piéton je ne vois
pas ce qui techniquement laisse à penser
que pour des motards il y aura un
empêche ment technique apporter les
caméras piétons et je pense que
l'enquête du lycien ne peut pas se baser
uniquement sur de la vidéo surveillance
ou sur des visios faites par des
citoyens qui étaient présents à ce
moment-là s'il n'y avait pas eu de
vidéosurveillance et s'il n'avait pas
été présent ces citoyens filmant la
scène qu'est-ce qu'on aurait pu
interpréter du du sujet donc je serai
heureux de vous entendre en la matière
merci même la présentation
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues bon je
vais me répéter d'autres l'ont dit avant
moi et c'est bien que nous le
partageions rien ne justifie
effectivement
les violences mais quand même rien ne
justifiait aussi la mort d'un enfant de
17 ans il faut que les choses soient
quand même clair de ce point de ce point
de vue là alors moi aussi j'étais à la
réunion convoquée par madame la Première
ministre mardi dernier et je lui ai dit
que nous avions déjà traversé deux
phases la première c'est la phase de
l'émotion
et la seconde c'est ce sont les
violences
inadmissibles que je condamne très
fortement et je ne reviens pas sur tout
ce qui a été saccagé dans notre pays et
les attaques scandaleuses contre des
élus et donc si la situation est moins
tendue aujourd'hui je crois que nous
devons être clairvoyants nous ne sommes
pas à l'abri d'une possible troisième
phase donc dans ces conditions je pense
qu'il faut rapidement apporter des
réponses à court à moyen et à long terme
pour rester sur le champ de la sécurité
parce que j'aurais pu venir aussi sur
d'autres champs mais sur celui de la
sécurité et du maintien de l'ordre je
sais que l'équation entre la prévention
l'accompagnement et la protection que
doivent porter la police c'est cette
équation c'est un véritable défi
à relever par les policiers eux-mêmes au
quotidien c'est un métier difficile
d'être policier et je trouve que c'est
la situation est d'autant plus
inquiétante que
la classe certaines personnes de la
classe politique
en rajoute fond de la surenchère des
amalgames douteux des propos qui bien
évidemment encore une fois font le lien
entre sécurité et immigration avec tout
le respect que j'ai pour vous Madame est
stage brignot et je ne reviendrai pas
sur les propos de Monsieur Kanner mais
vous voyez dans une cour d'école ou à la
sortie de l'école quand un gamin de 8
ans qui a le teint un peu bronzé
on pense que c'est un immigré alors que
c'est son arrière-grand-père qui est
arrivé en France c'est pas son
grand-père c'est pas son papa c'est son
arrière-grand-père ce môme et français
je suis française je suis française et
je suis Alexis c'est la question c'est
ce que vous avez évoqué Madame Moustache
prizeaux et je dis attention attention
vous mettez de l'huile sur le feu avec
vos propos
bah oui c'est sérieux bien évidemment
que c'est sérieux
donc et puis je crois qu'en Tom en tant
qu'homme et femme politique et surtout
en tant que parlementaire on ne peut pas
s'exonérer d'un certain nombre de choses
certes le gouvernement propose des lois
mais ces lois ce sont les parlementaires
qui les votent donc nous sommes
responsables aussi de la situation nous
avons des responsabilités et il serait
quand même assez inquiétant de
s'exonérer de ces responsabilités nous
votons la loi et donc les missions qui
sont confiées aux policiers c'est nous
qui lui avons qui leur avons conféré ces
missions et donc monsieur le ministre
moi vous savez j'ai plusieurs dadas
concernant les policiers celui de la
formation bien évidemment des policiers
je pense qu'il faut la renforcer tout en
tant que la durée de formation et puis
celui du retour à une police de
proximité je suis désolé depuis qu'il
n'existe plus de police de proximité
partout dans notre pays les liens se
sont délités entre
je n'ai pas dit que c'était la faute à
Sarkozy madame madame stage Bruno vous
savez j'ai Louis très fine mais c'est un
constat depuis qu'il n'y a plus de
police de proximité dans notre pays les
liens se sont délités entre les forces
de police et la jeunesse et moi
j'aimerais bien que Monsieur le Ministre
répondent est-ce qu'il a l'intention de
revenir à cette fonction de nos
policiers merci madame la présidente
Madame la présente Gatel merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre merci
très sincère pour votre total engagement
et votre transparence et merci aussi à
toutes les forces de l'ordre qui sont si
sollicités si éprouvées et parfois même
accablé mes collègues ont chacun évoquer
un angle des choses et ceci montre bien
que nous devons être aujourd'hui dans
une approche systémique parce que je
crois que les causes et les réponses
sont multi FLAC factorielle et
qu'au-delà de la crise que nous
traversons je pense que le mal est
profond et que la révolte sous toutes
ses formes y compris dans nos campagnes
parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle des
révoltes
urbaines il y a quelques temps parlait
de la révolte des ruraux tous la couve
et chacun de nous en tant des personnes
extrêmement modérées aujourd'hui dire
que demain elle voteront différemment et
que il n'y a plus aucun tabou sur
certains sujets et que il y a une
attente très forte de retour alors de
retour au vivre ensemble et l'ordre vous
l'avez dit vous-même et la sécurité sur
la meilleure protection des plus faibles
en tout cas si on s'intéresse à la
situation et au comportement des plus
jeunes en Afrique je crois que l'on dit
il faut tout un village pour éduquer un
enfant et je pense que c'est très vrai
je pense monsieur le ministre vous
n'êtes en vous êtes en charge des
questions de sécurité mais on ne peut
pas ne pas parler
tout le reste notamment en matière de
prévention la famille et le premier lieu
d'éducation il deviendra l'idée de
personnes de rejeter le principe de
responsabilité individuelle et moi je
suis très sensible à l'interpellation de
notre collègue qui parle de la nécessité
parfois de protéger les enfants et de
les mettre à l'abri et leur donner une
chance de s'émanciper et de s'éduquer
parfois hélas en quittant leur famille
pour aller dans des lieux qui sont des
lieux d'éducation qui doivent être
positives la deuxième chose Monsieur le
Ministre c'est que je rejoins un peu la
présidente assassine dans les zones de
gendarmerie nous voyons que les
gendarmes vivent au milieu de la
population moi j'étais mère j'ai vu le
chef de gendarmerie jouait au foot avec
d'autres ses enfants aller à la même
école moi je ne souhaite pas transformer
le policier en coach sportif mais il
n'empêche que quand vous rencontrez les
au quotidien dans votre vie vous les
regardez de manière différente et vous
n'êtes plus face à face dans des moments
de tension et de violence et moi je
crois à une présence appelons ça la
police de proximité sans connotation
d'époque voilà mais je crois qu'il y a
sans doute de la prévention qui
donnerait un rôle sans doute différent à
la police mais nous préserverait enfin
Monsieur le Ministre dernière question
s'adresse pas vous mais encore une fois
moi je pense que vous êtes au centre de
tout et qu'il y a une vraie question sur
la mixité oui au sang moi je suis très
contente qu'on dit ça bien heureux celui
qui est au sang bref je reviens madame
de la ganterie à mon propos je pense
qu'on a un vrai je pense qu'on a un vrai
sujet sur les conditions de vie et
l'assignation à résidence de certaines
personnes à la campagne comme à la ville
et je pense que si nous confions aux
élus locaux la gestion notamment du
logement social je pense qu'elle serait
plus heureuse parce qu'il y aurait une
mixité sociale qui serait pratiqué en
matière de dentelle et je pense que sans
doute qu'il y aurait moins de tension et
moins de ghetto qu'en pensez-vous
monsieur ça devait se terminer par une
question je vous remercie merci dernière
intervention madame Dominique verrière
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je voudrais tout d'abord
saluer en fait les habitants de de ces
quartiers politiques de la ville qui
pour beaucoup se sont engagés pour
sauver des bâtiments et ne pas forcément
laisser faire essayer d'empêcher toutes
ces détériorations car ils n'ont pas
oublié qu'ils en étaient les premières
victimes et nous ne devons pas l'oublier
non plus donc je voulais le saluer
derrière ces émeutes il semblerait qu'il
y ait quand même une organisation
facilité par des messageries ou les
réseaux sociaux souhaitent mais une
organisation et d'ailleurs le fait que
vous ayez tout d'abord arrêter des
jeunes et que plus vous avancez dans vos
investigations et plus vous arrêtez des
plus vieux montre là encore qu'il doit
bien y avoir une organisation alors
quelle est ce type d'organisation est-ce
que ce serait lié au trafic de drogue
comme on le dit souvent qui profite de
ce chaos par ailleurs on voit vous
l'avez dit vous-même que vous avez les
forces de sécurité intérieure on saisit
encore 300 kg de mortier si j'ai bien
compris
sont-ils en train de se réarmer doit-on
effectivement le craindre
et ça je me fais donc l'écho de ce que
vient de dire notre collègue Catherine
difolco et donc que faire pour anéantir
le pouvoir de cela et enfin j'arrive au
maire célibataire alors je crois
vraiment à l'autorité parentale et je
crois pas que une mère soit forcément
plus faible qu'un homme mais malgré tout
le maire de l'ail des roses elle a dit
lui-même
certaines mères n'y arrivent plus voir
sont elles-mêmes victimes de leurs
enfants qui souvent sont tombés sous
l'influence de ces fameuses
organisateurs dont je parlais un peu
plus avant alors moi je vais vous parler
des pairs où sont-ils les pairs et
permettez-moi de pousser un coup de
gueule quand je vois le père de Noël qui
se porte partie civile
il ne faut quand même pas avoir beaucoup
de fierté pour ne pas avoir été là pour
élever son enfant mais essayer de
profiter de sa mort
merci Madame Berrien bien heureux
interventions
nous appartient maintenant de répondre
un peu plus de 5 minutes quand même
merci c'est gentil merci monsieur le
Président
peut-être deux mots de mots généraux et
puis répondre à chacune de vos questions
il a été fait référence dans les médias
et même ici ou là par vos interventions
aux émeutes dites de 2005
je voudrais comparer des choses et
évidemment dire qu'il y a des choses
très différentes en 2005 à 21 jours
d'émeutes et au bout du dixième jour le
gouvernement de la République sur
demande du Président de la République si
je me rappelle dans l'histoire politique
impose à son ministre de l'Intérieur de
l'époque l'état d'urgence
on voit que d'ailleurs ça a duré malgré
l'état d'urgence puisqu'il y a eu plus
de jours d'émeutes après qu'avant et
chacun se rappelle sans doute que c'est
une vague de froid extrêmement forte qui
a calmé une partie des ardeurs des
délinquants ou des émeutiers de l'époque
ils étaient plus âgés beaucoup plus âgés
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai demandé qu'on me
sorte les comparaisons je ne les ai pas
encore mais à coup sûr ils étaient plus
âgés
moins de vide était concernée
chacun se rappelle d'ailleurs que
Marseille à l'époque n'avait pas connu
des meute parce qu'on expliquait que
trafic de drogue calmé les ardeurs
de ceux qui voulaient être ébutier il
n'y avait pas de réseaux sociaux il me
semble que LCI devait être la seule la
chaîne de formation continue mais je
n'ai plus de bons souvenirs en tout cas
c'était pas tout à fait demande
médiatique et de même nom de mimétique
et il y avait malgré tout
il y avait eu malgré tout à l'époque
d'abord de la part me semble-t-il des
décideurs politiques à défaut de
jugement sur ce qui était arrivé dans
l'affaire initiale
et par ailleurs qui a sans doute
contribué
à l'excitation et à des vacances et par
ailleurs à la fin je constate qu'il y
avait aussi des revendications sociales
d'où les plans et notamment chacun s'en
souvient des fameux plan Borlo et autres
qui ont répondu à ces difficultés là
nous avons des choses très différentes
quatre jours d'émeutes
nous avons
jusqu'à présent à utiliser l'état
d'urgence d'ailleurs je constate que si
personne ne reproche et parfois ça nous
a reprochait médiatiquement mais nous
revoche d'avoir pris l'état d'urgence je
suis pas sûr qu'il nous aurait beaucoup
aidé et d'ailleurs je n'ai pas proposé
au Président de la République et la
première ministre puisque l'état
d'urgence avec comme grand avantage
comme dans un état d'urgence terroriste
de faire des perquisitions
administratives l'idée de donner au
minisateur les pouvoirs qu'on les
procureurs de la République ou les juges
comme là il n'y avait pas d'organisation
criminelle comme telles que nous l'avons
vu il y a d'autres organisations j'y
reviendrai même à ma satisatrice les
perquisitions administratives sauf et on
va pas à l'instant où nous en parlions
n'étaient pas d'une utilité
d'une grande efficacité j'ai fait le
pari que la démonstration de force et
d'interpellation était de nature à
calmer une partie des émeutiers dont je
veux dire ici que d'après des services
de Missan intérieur mais ce sont des
chiffres qui forcément ne sont pas
scientifiques ils étaient entre 8000 et
peut-être un peu plus peut-être un peu
moins les groupes très mobiles souvent
cagoulés mais on peut pas considérer
qu'il y avait des centaines de milliers
de personnes dans ces quartiers ou des
millions de personnes vivent qui se sont
rebeller contre la République donc je
pense que même si les images sont
extrêmement choquantes même si des
agitations et les dégradations sont
extrêmement fortes même s'il y a 800
policiers gendarmes blessés fort
heureusement aucun la pronostic vital
engagé je veux ici dire qu'il s'agit de
tout au plus de quelques milliers de
personnes qui ont commis ces difficultés
ce qui est à la fois un problème très
important et en même temps nous ne
permet pas de mettre dans le même sac
tous les habitants des quartiers
populaires bon
le deuxième sujet que je voudrais
évoquer avec vous c'est celui de la
police
d'ailleurs je reviendrai peut-être pour
répondre à Madame de La Gontrie j'en
excuse auprès du sénateur du rein et qui
connaît le respect que m'inspire son
travail si je n'ai pas été très complet
pour la question au gouvernement
évidemment
la police nationale et avec la
gendarmerie je trouve que le débat peut
gendarmerie je l'entends monter mais il
est pas très correct d'abord parce que
il y a 25% des vacances aux autres
gendarmerie 75% de police chacun
s'accordera à dire que c'est pas le même
type de délinquance
deuxièmement il y a encore quelques
années vous discutiez avec le ministre
de l'époque de la Réforme de la
gendarmerie nationale puisque dans
l'affaire des Traoré à Persan c'était
exactement les mêmes discussions autour
d'un supposé racisme de se poser mauvais
interpellation
il y a du bon dans la gendarmerie
nationale il y a du monde dans la police
nationale je crois qu'ils ne font pas
totalement le même métier je veux
constater avec vous cependant que 80%
d'intervention des gendarmes mobiles
sont en zone police et d'ailleurs quand
on dit il y a un rapport police
population je pense que si on avait un
on peut toujours discuter d'ailleurs
j'aime pas trop ce mot parce que pour
moi la police à gendarmerie ils sont
dans la population ils sont pas à part
ils ont des enfants qui vont à l'école
ils ont des habitations qu'ils ont des
des maris des femmes des parents ils
changent de métier ils sont issus de la
population c'est pas une population à
part il rentre pas dans le caserne au
commissariat sans jamais rencontrer leur
boulanger ou leurs voisins bon donc je
trouve que les distinguer des
populations est insultant pour eux mais
je comprends ce qu'on veut dire par ce
mot je ne veux pas le rejeter par
principe je crois que il n'y a pas dans
le statut militaire de la gendarmerie
nationale dans sa formation des choses
qui expliquerait que ça irait mieux que
des gendarmes avec des policiers
puisqu'on peut trouver bien des exemples
qui montrent que dans les villes
qui se sont agrandis et qui sont en zone
gendarmerie c'est le cas dans je prends
l'exemple de Libourne par exemple en
Gironde ou c'est le cas de Persan ils
connaissent ces mêmes difficultés on
peut sans doute inspirer ici ou là des
pratiques des uns et des autres mais je
ne suis pas sûr qu'ils ne martingale
quelque part et en disant ça j'ai le
plus grand respect bien sûr pour le
travail légendaire mais pour le travail
des policiers le but du ministère
intérieur c'est de prendre le meilleur
des deux forces et pas le moins bon des
deux forces parce que aussi de moins bon
de chaque côté c'est pour ça qu'il faut
faire très attention en le rapprochement
on aura l'occasion sans doute de parler
de la philosophie du cristal intérieur
plus tard je veux dire que la police
si on sent si on veut bien
mettre ça à son crédit elle est le
réceptacle tout ce qui n'est pas allé
tout ce qui n'a pas aller jusqu'à
présent dans la société pour moi je vais
prendre un exemple qui voudra parler à
ceux qui sont attentifs aux questions
médicales ce sont les urgentistes de la
société si quelqu'un fume toute la
journée bois toute la journée
est stressé et en surcharge pondérale et
vit dans des conditions de non-respects
de son corps il faut pas s'étonner qu'il
fasse une crise cardiaque ou un AVC
qu'est-ce qu'on fera on appellera les
pompiers ou le SAMU ils interviendront
le plus rapidement possible espérons-le
avec la formation la plus efficace
possible espérons-le avec les
technologies les plus modernes possibles
espérons-le et ils seront pas la vie de
cette personne
si cette personne meurt nous serions
bien
comment dirais-je sera bien méchant de
considérer que c'est dur gentil ce qui a
passé de sauver et qu'il faudrait
davantage encore le sélectionner
davantage encore exiger les choses de
lui sans doute qui peut encore
s'améliorer être plus rapide avant de
meilleur moyen être plus attentif à la
médecine enfin c'est pas lui
personnellement qui est responsable de
cette mort ici cette personne ne meurt
pas et qu'il l'a sauvé c'est pas lui qui
va lui faire changer d'attitude de ne
plus boire de ne plus manger de maigrir
c'est son médecin généraliste c'est
s'habitudes alimentaires c'est peut-être
même ses parents c'est peut-être son
mode de vie donc je pense que la police
cristallise quand je dis la police ce
sont les forces de l'ordre cristallise
évidemment des faits médiatiques et
extrêmement complexe ce ministère de
l'Intérieur est un mystère où tous les
jours il se passe de très nombreuses
horreurs que fort heureusement toute
opinion ne connaît pas parce que je
crois qu'elle serait alors aussi déprimé
que les membres de mon cabinet bien
évidemment mais c'est l'arrivée et après
la police chacun le sait la justice
l'arrivée de toutes les difficultés que
la société a pas su réglé avant donc moi
je veux bien tout ce qu'on veut et les
policiers parfois connaissent des
difficultés fortes y compris dans leur
vie personnelle parfois de management
qui sont extrêmement toxiques mais je
pense que avant de poser ce genre de
questions pour se dire qu'ils ont une
charge et une surcharge physique et
psychologique très grande quand
l'éducation va mieux quand l'intégration
a réussi quand le logement est efficace
parce qu'on sait tous qu'il y a des
liens entre tout ça et d'autres encore
alors je crois que il y aurait moins de
travail pour nos policiers alors
cependant pour répondre à la question de
la Gontrie très très concrètement même
la construit merci de des propos que
vous avez tenus et merci d'ailleurs au
groupe socialiste au sens large et à
tous ceux qui sont ici d'avoir tenu ses
propos
c'est un policier qui a été mis en
examen c'est pas tous les policiers qui
ont été mis en examen
alors est-ce qu'un policier peut
commettre des erreurs oui bien sûr
est-ce qu'il y a à améliorer la
formation sans aucun doute d'ailleurs
nous avons posé quatre mois de plus la
première formation
faut-il faire davantage sans doute sans
doute faut-il mieux sélectionner les
policiers très certainement je constate
avec vous si vous me le permettez que je
suis à la tête d'un ministère ou à part
les commissaire de police
ce que nous recrutons c'est souvent des
enfants pour apprendre notre mot de 18
de 19 de 20 ans qui n'ont pas fait de
très grandes études et qui choisissent
ce service de la nation par la police
gendarmerie je ne suis pas la tête mais
ça de la justice où les gens peuvent des
concours avec plus 4 bac + 5 ou
éducation nationale aux gens sont très
mal payés par ailleurs comme les
policiers mais enfin ils ont un capital
social très important
mettons-nous quelques instants à la
place d'un majorité majorité de jeunes
qui choisissent ce service de la police
et de gendarmerie que nous devons former
nous
sauf que oui ça demande une exigence
supplémentaire parce qu'en plus ces
personnes ont la contrainte légitime des
armes et donc par ailleurs une
responsabilité supplémentaire et à nous
savoir pourquoi et pour quelle raison
ils veulent rentrer dans la police
gendarmerie c'est la première question
que je pose à des policiers à des
gendarmes quand je les croise dans
l'école
on est tous toujours très touchés par la
simple de nos témoignages et il y a
parfois des questions qu'on peut se
poser donc 1 je veux dire que oui on
doit améliorer sans cesse et ce sera un
travail jamais terminé le travail des
policiers et des gendarmes sans aucun
doute je suis le premier à ne pas
accepter à son instant qu'on tutoie les
personnes
c'est inacceptable qu'on est 15 ans
qu'on soit étranger en situation
irrégulière ou qu'on soit présent
directeur général d'une société on ne
peut pas tutoyer les personnes alors
évidemment c'est plus facile à dire dans
les fauteuils du Sénat que sur le
terrain mais c'est la honneur de la
prestationnel nous ne sommes pas une
bande rivale contre une autre bande
rivale c'est d'ailleurs pour ça monsieur
Durand et vous le savez que j'ai pris à
sa tombe de décision lorsque j'ai vu des
policiers manifestés en cagoule on n'est
pas une bande rivale contre une autre
bande rivale c'est pas ça la République
donc oui il faut sans cesse améliorer un
travail difficile de formation des
policiers oui vous avez raison Madame la
Gontrie trois tirs administratifs c'est
pas assez notamment les tirs dit en
mouvement parce que c'est ça la
difficulté quand je suis arrivé au
ministère de la table à la Gaudry 60%
des policiers seulement valeur 3 tirs
administratifs c'est leur administration
qui est responsable de leur sécurité et
la première chose que fait l'IGPN ou
l'iggène c'est de vérifier que le
policier a fait trois tirs
administratifs et si il l'a pas fait il
le sanctionne mais c'est pas lui qui
refuse de faire trottirer administratif
c'est qu'il y a pas assez de stands de
tir c'est qu'il y a pas assez de temps
pour la formation c'est nous les les
employeurs de ces policiers qui sont
responsables vous avez raison il faut
largement améliorer ça je crois que la
loi que vous avez votée nous permet de
le faire
vous avez raison aussi également il faut
sans doute que nous nous posions des
questions de compréhension du monde dans
lequel vivent les policiers des
gendarmes peut-être que le policier et
le gendarme et c'est le cas de toute
personne qui travaille finalement dans
sa filière professionnelle de se pose
pas assez de questions parce que par
manque de temps par manque de formation
par manque d'action de son
administration par management aussi la
question dans quel monde il évolue mais
cependant madame de La Gontrie
accordez-moi quand même
qu'on ne peut pas tout à fait dire qu'il
faut changer les lois j'entends la
question sur la loi de février 2017
que le gouvernement de Monsieur
Cazeneuve a proposé dans d'autres
circonstances très certainement c'est
pas parce qu'un policier ne respecte pas
la loi qu'il faut changer forcément
cette loi d'ailleurs je constate que
beaucoup veulent que désormais je dis
giver sur le coup de l'émotion non non
j'ai beaucoup
j'ai dit beaucoup
ce monsieur ce policier qui est encore
une fois a droit à la présomption
innocence et je ne suis pas procureur de
la République je ne suis pas juge
n'a manifestement de mon point de vue et
je ne suis pas spécialiste au sens
formateur de la question mais je me
posais évidemment poser des questions
avant d'apporter une réponse publique
mais seulement pas respecté la loi de
parce que quelqu'un ne respecte pas une
loi il faudrait la changer c'est absurde
si quelqu'un fait du 184 km/h sur
l'autoroute BC la vitesse excessive de
130 à 120 ne résoudra rien puisque par
définition il ne respecte pas cette
vitesse je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas
réfléchir aux conditions d'emploi des
forces je dis que ça me paraît une
réponse trop rapide et trop facile
premièrement deuxièmement je veux dire
ici que
l'intervention de la police nationale
gendarmerie c'est la conséquence de 10
ans de difficultés entre pays qui ont
commencé avec des attentats
les attentats terroristes
un certain nombre de violences
inexcusables qui relève très souvent des
violences urbaines qui attressement des
forcené parce que le premier travail des
policiers de gendarmes c'est souvent
intervenir sur des forçonnés où ils
ouvrent le feu des reflets obtempérer
alors j'ai bien compris les questions
qui m'ont été posées je vais vous donner
les réponses j'espère le plus précise
possible sur les refus de tempérer en
2022 il y en a eu 25800 fait connu par
les services de police et de gendarmerie
c'est à dire en moyenne un refus
d'obtempérer tous les 20 minutes
5329 dans des circonstances exposant
directement autrui le risque d'abord
de 2016 à 2022 il y a eu une hausse de
5,8% pour les refus et 27,3%
d'augmentation pour l'effet de reflet de
tempéré dans les circonstances exposant
directement quelqu'un à la mort
et si je prends le travail qui est fait
par les policiers donc parce que je vous
ai donné les chiffres offerts simples et
c'est ce qu'on a constaté c'est pas ceux
qui existent au sens où les policiers
rames sont pas là qui amènent un
policier demandant de s'arrêter en ayant
constaté la fraction on constate qu'ils
ont augmenté 220 6% et de même que le
nombre de récidives par le même
conducteur d'un véhicule augmenté de
155%
. dans ces conditions est-ce que les
policiers légendaires notamment la loi
depuis 2017 augmentent leur intervention
pour tirer la réponse est non là encore
je veux dire que dans le débat qu'on a
eu c'est faux c'est pas parce qu'un
policier n'aurait pas respecté 2017 que
il y a une augmentation comme je l'ai lu
par 5 des tirs en zone police comme en
zone gendarmerie
en 2013 c'est le dernier enfin le
chiffre est plutôt que j'ai
226 déclarations de tir opérationnelle
et accidentelle de manière générale
usage sur véhicule en mouvement 133
en 2016 donc au moment où j'imagine le
gouvernement de ce Cazeneuve a été
inspiré pour prendre sa législation 255
tirs administratifs 313
usages de l'arme volontaires
opérationnelles en position gendarmerie
181 sur véhicule en mouvement
en 2017 l'année de la loi 394 tirs
opérationnels 313 pardon 429 pardon
usage de l'inventaire opérationnelle et
sur les vécurvements 255 prenons
l'exemple alors 2020 c'est une année
covid me paraît pas une bonne
comparaison mais 2021 qui était une
année covid à moitié 290 tirs
opérationnels 341
usages volonté opérationnels 201 sur les
clients mouvements 2022 qui est une
année pleine sans covid 285 déclarations
de tir opérationnels 317 usages d'armes
opérationnels 168 véhicules à mouvement
c'est-à-dire que la police à gendarmerie
c'est le contraire de ce qu'on raconte
il y a de plus en plus de tempérés et
j'utilise de moins en moins leurs armes
ça c'est la vérité des chiffres et j'ai
le détail police et gendarmerie si vous
le souhaitez monsieur le créateur je
voulais passerai c'est exactement la
même chose dans les deux façons il n'y
en a pas une qui augmente et une qui
baisse les deux baisses
donc je crois que on peut se poser des
questions encore une fois intérieur
devant
l'incroyable force qu'on les faits de
l'ordre par définition et la contrariété
que nous console Parlement peut se poser
toutes les questions qu'il faut après
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que la loi
que venait de voter n'a pas encore
conduit le produit ses effets puisque
nous sommes dans la première année
budgétaire de cette transformation et
encore une fois nous avons augmenté de
quatre mois la formation c'est un tiers
nous avons augmenté de 50% la formation
continue mais je veux dire que la police
et la gendarmerie contrairement à ce que
j'ai entendu et c'est tout à fait faux
ne tire pas plus qu'avant et oui les
autres opérés augmente bien plus
qu'avant ça pose des tas de questions
les gens qui conduisent sans permis les
gens qui viennent de cambrioler les gens
qui ont de la drogue les gens qui ont de
l'alcool les gens qui respectent plus
aucune autorité c'est tout à fait vrai
il y a sans doute beaucoup de raisons
assez offertes opérer mais il n'est pas
vrai comme j'ai lu et relu et re relu
que nous augmenterions les consignes de
tir de les tirs les consignes et donc
les tirs sur les sur les reflets alors
d'autres questions ont été posées alors
madame Serge Regnault vous posez une
question difficile
je vais essayer de répondre non
seulement ce que je pense mais je crois
être la vérité
je n'ai pas de réponse scientifique
puisque par définition nous n'avons pas
encore le retour exact de l'intégralité
des personnes que nous avons interpellé
je veux ici vous dire que président de
la République a demandé de regarder ce à
moi-même de postérieur à aux
interpellations au travail de la justice
de faire très rapidement une étude
sociologique pour savoir qui sont ces
personnes
et je suis certain que le Président de
la République nous autorisera à rendre
public cette étude sociologique je veux
dire en dehors du travail des policiers
des gendarmes que des gens extérieurs
puissent regarder ce qui s'est passé
moi je n'y ai pas vu j'ai fait une
quinzaine de commissariats en 4 jours la
nuit et la première chose que je fais
quand je me pose de garde c'est que je
demande la liste des personnes qui sont
gardées mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
jusqu'à présent bah beaucoup dit que
c'était des gens pour violence
intrafamiliales on peut tous faire
l'expérience je vous ai parlementaire
vous aider quand vous le souhaitez bien
évidemment ça va de la République j'ai
regardé et faites-le dans vos
commissariats de gendarmerie qui sont
ces gens oui il y a des gens qui
apparemment pourraient être issus
d'immigration mais il y a eu beaucoup de
Kevin et de Matteo si je peux me
permettre
il y en a eu aussi et l'explication
n'est pas n'est pas
l'explication seulement identitaire me
paraît très erronée
je ne veux pas ici dire je pense qu'une
explication
identitaire serait trompé et puis
surtout je pense que serait une critique
assez fort de ce qui s'est passé parce
que si je fais un rapide calcul 17 ans
de moyenne c'est à dire qu'ils sont nés
sous la présidence de Jacques Chirac ça
veut dire que reprocher aujourd'hui
imaginez d'ici Ferrer immédiatement sur
une question migratoire
me paraît déjà trop tard madame la
sénatrice si jamais c'était votre
solution en revanche la question de
l'intégration et la réussite de
l'assimilation est une question
intéressante
et je crois que la posée simplement en
termes d'identitaire serait une réponse
trop facile mais encore une fois c'est
ce que je dis tout à l'heure il faut il
faut se poser sur les sur les sur les
questions
est-ce que l'explication sociale est la
seule réponse je ne le crois pas
totalement non plus d'abord ce serait
une insulte extrêmement forte à tous
ceux qui suivent des familles très
modestes
travaillent et respectent l'ordre et
c'est pas parce que on connaît des
situations très modestes qu'on attaque
des bibliothèques qu'on attaque des CCAS
on a attaqué des CCAS voilà chacun sait
ce que ça veut dire des postes dans des
quartiers populaires et vous savez très
concrètement moi dans ma ville ou dans
la ville de Reims que j'étais visité en
quartier populaire attaquer les deux
postes des deux quartiers populaires
c'est à dire que les minima sociaux qui
sont parfois critiqués des mandats que
toucheront pas les gens leur propre
famille donc l'explication ne peut pas
être que sociale étant issue
d'immigration par ma famille et étant
issu une famille modeste par ma famille
je pense qu'il y a une part de liberté
de chaque individu de se sortir de son
déterminisme et que ce travail de la
République de l'aider à sortir se
déterminisme il peut y avoir des
réflexes identitaires ou communautaires
il peut y avoir des réflexes de classes
sociales mais je crois que le résine de
la République c'est de ne pas
discriminer les gens soit social soit
par leur classe d'origine éthique je ne
suis pas naïf madame la sénatrice je dis
juste que je ne veux pas confondre les
choses il me semble j'ai toujours
combattu les discours qui consistaient à
dire qu'il y avait des gens qui
intrasement si j'ose dire
essentiellement au sens de l'essence
était prédéterminé sinon on aurait du
mal à comprendre comment beaucoup
d'entre eux servent dans l'armée
française dans la police française moi
je sais bien c'est parce que vous avez
dit mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
y a aussi beaucoup d'enfants issues de
migration que je croise dans les
couloirs de la police nationale que je
croise à la mairie que je croise à la
gendarmerie nationale que je croise dans
les armées et je crois et je crois et je
crois que c'est une question plus
d'intégration
et d'actions que fait la République pour
les aider à s'intégrer de
responsabilisation des personnes
individuellement que de déterminisme
d'origine ethnique ou sociale
je veux dire ce monsieur Durin que je
pense que j'ai répondu sur la le refus
de repérer on pourra en parler à l'envie
et sans doute de manière un peu plus
calme que j'ai été
en désapprobation du communiqué du
syndicat Alliance et que j'ai été dit
même sur une chaîne de grand écoute
puisque c'était au journal de télévisé
de TF1 que ce n'était pas mémo après moi
monsieur Center j'ai deux réflexions
personnelles la première c'est que la
liberté syndicale elle est pour tout le
monde
pour tout le monde je ne corrige aucun
communiqué d'aucun syndicats bon oui
encore heureux mais on voudrait que je
corrige et communiquer du syndicat
Alliance je ne suis pas adhérent du
syndicat Alliance ni des autres
syndicats par ailleurs et je ce n'est
pas moi de faire la police de la pensée
ils ont sorti à communiquer il y a une
discussion politique je crois qu'il
s'attendait à cette réaction politique
point j'ai dit aux responsables
d'alliance pour qui personnellement j'ai
le plus grand respect comme pour tous
les syndicats de policiers qui font un
travail très compliqué très difficile et
qui défendent l'intérêt des
fonctionnaires de police que ça me
paraissait pas les mots que j'aurais
utilisés dans le contexte en plus dans
lequel nous étions point une fois que
j'ai dit ça je veux aussi dire par
ailleurs
que beaucoup de policiers beaucoup de
gendarmes
tout en ayant peut-être un avis
identique à celui du communiqué du
syndicat Alliance ou vous considérant
que les politiques d'affront pas assez
vous considérons que ils subissent
beaucoup de difficultés ou considérant
comme dirait même incontrie elle a
parfaitement raison même si nous
augmentons cette rémunération qui sont
mal payés
beaucoup de policiers et de gendarmes
ont été
malgré leur opinion politique
philosophique ou religieuse totalement
au rendez-vous de ce qu'a demandé la
République moi j'ai pas eu un mouvement
de grève un mouvement de désapprobation
et encore une fois je le redire même si
il y a 10 enquêtes igpn iggn et jusqu'au
bout avoir des dizaines de milliers
d'intervention pour avoir 4000
interpellation dans un contexte où les
maisons brûlées on envoyait le raid pour
libérer des élus dans des mairies on
envoyait le GIGN pour pouvoir arrêter
des émeutiers des types du GIGN que j'ai
croisé excusez-moi c'était que des
garçons à Torcy moi expliquer que dans
des communes où ils sont allés il y
avait 50 et Métiers ils étaient quatre
bon ils ont arrêté ces personnes pour
brûler une mairie pour brûler une
médiathèque moi je veux leur dire que
j'ai très bien compris qu'ils avaient
été au rendez-vous de la République et
qu'ils avaient compris qu'on avait
besoin d'eux
une fois que j'ai dit ça les syndicats
ils ont la liberté de dire ce qu'ils
souhaitent et vous avez la liberté bien
évidemment ce sénateur de critiquer ce
sujet
les ministres que vous évoquez ont
existé à Angers et à Chambéry notamment
documenté par le ministère de
l'Intérieur nous avons procédé à des
interpellations
nous avons présenté ces personnes devant
la justice
nous verrons bien à quelle réponse
pénale ils auront je veux aussi dire que
des militants du train à gauche comme
l'a dit monsieur le président de la
commission des lois ont participé de
façon extrêmement rare mais quand même à
des attaques je pense qu'au quartier du
Mirail à Toulouse notamment tout au
début ont essayé de faire ce qu'on
appelle une convergence des luttes
ils n'ont pas réussi et je veux dire ici
que moins de 2% des personnes que nous
avons interpellées sont connues des
services de renseignement et à ma
connaissance un seul fichier
donc on voit bien qu'il n'y a pas eu de
convergence des luttes même si ça avait
été souhaité
donc oui les milices d'extrême droite
doivent être absolument combattus nous
regarderons d'ailleurs comment on peut
documenter d'éventuelles dissolution
s'il existait des groupements faits des
associations on y travaille en ce moment
monsieur le sénateur et oui le combat
contre l'ultra gauche qui profite et qui
veut mettre bas notre système
républicain doit être également combattu
je veux dire par ailleurs que il y a eu
effectivement à Lorient manifestement
une mobilisation en dehors de tout cadre
bien sûr de certains militaires
j'aimerais remercie le ministère des
armées d'avoir ouvert une enquête sur ce
qui s'est passé à Lorient à notre
connaissance je peux être que d'accord
avec l'intervention de Madame Lerbier et
pas simplement parce que je suis grand
électeur du Nord monsieur le monsieur
Président d'accovision eucovision je
n'ai pas dit pour qui je voter je n'ai
pas dit pour qui je voter monsieur le
Président canner et j'ai remarqué qu'en
ce temps de campagne satoriale vous avez
dit du bien du ministre de l'Intérieur
et vous l'avez même citer je saurai m'en
souvenir je saurai mon souvenir
d'autres convergences je veux dire
qu'elle a je crois parfaitement raison
et que et que je dois aussi je serai
assez curieux de savoir et peut-être que
l'étude de commander par le Président de
la République te permettra d'y répondre
combien de ces adolescents ou jeunes
adultes
faisaient partie de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ou en tout cas ont connu un
parcours parental extrêmement détérioré
peut-être que non
peut-être que on peut considérer vous le
connaissez bien ces sujets que lorsqu'on
connaît des difficultés extrêmement
fortes quand on est enfant on a tendance
à les reproduire Philippe Seguin a une
jolie phrase disait l'adulte est
toujours l'enfant qu'il était je pense
que c'est c'est vrai et d'où
l'importance des parents évidemment du
cadre familial sur les mortiers monsieur
sénateur bonhomme je pense avoir répondu
tout à l'heure en question au
gouvernement il faut absolument les
manger cette législation qui nous permet
peut-être de réglementer bien sûr ce
travail de de poursuite et et d'action
et de on en reparlera le président de la
République travailler
sur la question
de l'action et vous parler de l'action à
Lyon madame la sénatrice moi aussi c'est
une étude que j'ai demandé au ministère
de l'intérieur j'ai eu l'impression
confusément dans les remontées j'ai fait
5 nuits de suite dans les centres
opérationnels que la des villes qui
avait une caméra vidéo surveillance
et les villes qui permettaient à la
police nationale d'intervenir sur les
caméras vidéo surveillance je pense à la
ville de Lyon qui ne le permet pas
madame la sénatrice je crois qu'on a été
plus efficace que les villes qui
n'avaient pas de caméras sont nombreux
ou qui n'ont pas permis la police
intervenir c'est un fait je suis désolé
de le dire c'est un fait donc je crois
que pour corroborer c'est fait forcément
confus et peut-être avec un billet
psychologique de ma part nous avons
aussi demandé de regarder arrêt des
émeutes travail de police judiciaire et
présence de caméras de vidéoprotection
pour que la représentation nationale
puisqu'on a souvent ce débat puis savoir
ces éléments présents
à évoqué la question des caméras piétons
il a mille fois raison moi je salue le
travail qui a fait le ministre et le
premier Cazeneuve dans la loi qui est
parmi ces caméras piétons quand je suis
arrivé au ministère de l'Intérieur il y
avait 11000 caméras piétons il y en a
désormais 53000 et ils vont continuer à
augmenter je passerai monsieur le
centaudura connaissait sur le fait que
les caméras piétons d'abord étaient pas
très performantes elle ne couvrait pas
les elle ne couvraient pas les vacances
enfin on essaye donc on a relancé le
marché on a équipé tout ça sur désormais
individualisés on sait quelle caméra ce
qui n'était pas le cas auparavant
appartient à qui et dans quelles
conditions demain
c'est aujourd'hui puisqu'on le fait déjà
dans quelques commissariats grâce à la
loi sécurité globale que vous n'avez pas
voté mais c'est pas très grave mais le
président de la commission des lois et
la majorité l'ont voté mais je sais que
ce point aurait pu être partagé on va
pouvoir avoir le contenu des caméras en
direct également dans les centres
opérationnels
donc évidemment la consigne ministre de
l'intérieur comme pour le port du Rio et
pour les problèmes se durant il l'a vu
que j'ai rappelé à tous les effectifs
qui devaient évidemment le porter c'est
de porter ses caméras piétons oui comme
vous interrompons à cette audition de
Gérald Darmanin qui s'exprime devant les
sénateurs de la commission des lois à
propos et bien de ces journées des meute
qui ont suivi et bien la mort de Naël
tué par un policier mardi dernier 17 ans
est mort à Nanterre la semaine dernière
nous l'interrompons mais nous allons y
revenir dans quelques instants à 18h
exactement avec sens public et Thomas
Hugues qui consacrera notamment et bien
son premier débat à cette audition de
Gérald Darmanin qui se posera cette
question les politiques sont-ils à la
hauteur vous pouvez bien sûr voir et
revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site public sénat.fr notre nouvelle
plateforme où vous pouvez également
retrouver tous nos décryptages très
bonne soirée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]